okay good morning so today we do Dante
and Dante really
is the height of civilization it does
not get better than
Dante um I've taught Dante for three
years now this is my third time teaching
Dante and what's amazing about it is
that all students love Dante but also
each time I teach Dante I'm able to
discover new insights about Dante that I
didn't realized
before um my theory is
that Dante is someone you can spend your
entire life studying and you will never
truly understand his power his truth his
um Beauty okay so um we will do we will
spend two classes on
Dante um today and next Tuesday and this
will end the first
semester Dante is extremely complicated
I can I want to give you a glimpse into
how wonderful he is these next two
classes all right so let me give you a
quick introduction into Dante all right
so his book his of poetry is called the
Comedia the comedy it's not called The
Divine Comedy Divine Comedy is something
that we called later on okay he first
refer to as the Comedia why is it called
The Comedy well because um in writing
epics there are two Styles there's the
tragic or high and there's the comic or
low tragic means tragic High means that
it usually deals with gods and Kings and
it's written in extremely sophisticated
style comic LW means that it deals with
ordinary people and written in a common
vernacular um
at this um at this period in European
history this this is the year 1308 to 13
uh 21 okay those are those are the 13
years that he spends writing the the
comedy and he will die after he after he
finishes
it um at this point in European history
the high language is
Latin and what Donnie does which is very
interesting is he chooses to write it in
tusin and this is the of course the um
local language of Florence where he is
from and because the comeda is so
wonderfully produced tuskin will become
the official language of the Italian
Peninsula okay so in today in Italy they
speak the Tusan dialect of the
language The Divine Comedy it is an epic
divided into three uh structures
Dante goes on a spiritual
journey um into the cosmos in order to
seek truth to seek um God he starts off
in with a um midlife
crisis um and so he has a guy named
virtual who takes him through Inferno
okay and then they go to
purgatory and then he goes to Paradise
Paradise is heaven Inferno is hell and
Purgatory is the land the mountain in
between the infernal and
Paradise um today we will look at the
very
ending of the Divine Kony CLE
33 and I want to set up the
um po the
poem okay give you some context and some
background Dante is imper
and he's trying to figure out the
spiritual truth underlying the
universe and then as he goes on this
journey he concludes his journey journey
by meeting God okay but the problem with
God
is no one knows what it is it's a
mystery it's the biggest mystery in the
universe what is God God is there right
there but no one knows what it is God
God is surrounded by a a Heavenly Host
these are angels that have proved
themselves worthy to be around God and
these include people like Mary the
mother of Jesus um as well as Rachel and
um and Leah who we uh learned about when
we did the Hebrew
Bible and they have Absolut no idea who
God is either okay they're in a place
called The
eperium and Dante is being Guided by a
man named Bernard an angel okay St St
Bernard and to the left to the left is
God and he is this pristine ball of
light no one knows what it is not even
God knows what it is and over here is
the host okay um and at the very center
is
Mary what is amazing about Divine carony
is how d
restructures Christian
theology remember in Christian
theology Jesus is the
epicenter but in Dante's rendering of
Christian theology Mary is at the
center and the reason why is I yourself
this question is it a greater
miracle that a God could come to Earth
and die for our sins or is it a greater
miracle that a mortal woman is able to
give birth to a
God okay this is something that if you
think about it it's kind of shocking and
beading and that's what happens during
The Divine Comedy there are two uh
literary devices
that D will use throughout Divine Comedy
the first is the idea of
paradox think of Paradox as a
puzzle
okay what is the hand what is the sound
of one hand clapping okay a paradox a a
truth that seems like a contradiction he
will use this all the time and the other
is
structure okay the Divine Colony it is
mathematically precise it is brilliant
it is 100 Kos and there is so much
mathematics Within in The Divine Comedy
so to use a metaphor you can see Divine
Comedy as almost as an intellectual
jakea
puzzle the human mind does not like
contradictions the human mind does not
like paradoxes so what happens is this
if you are to engage to Divine Comedy
you are you become infraed in it you
become obsessed with it and then what
happens is your mind will slowly over
time all by itself you actually don't
have to do anything okay your mind will
start will start to unravel these
paradoxes and create a new truth of the
universe okay and so we are talking
about the creation for The Divine Comedy
of a
new mind for Humanity if Homer was the
father of Western civil oh sorry of
Greek civilization then Dante is the
father of modern European civilization
and the reason why is the Divine Kony
because it um is a jigzle that will uh
that will unravel the tubs of the
universe it becomes inal blue blint for
three major movements in Europe the
first is the Renaissance remember the
Renaissance starts in Florence
right second is the Protestant
Reformation a religious Revolution
against the Catholic church and the
third is the Sonic Revolution okay I
will show you today why that's the case
how implanted or imprinted in the
Poetry um are the seeds of these three
major
revolutions all right okay any questions
so far before I before we we look at
Divine
Comedy all right um dou could you um
okay so first thing to know about Divine
Comedy is that it is part of a literary
genre called apocalyptic literature
apocalyptic literature just
means god reveals reveals the truth to
us through a prophet or a poet okay so
this is Ezekiel which is one of the
earliest books of the Hebrew Bible and
um this really starts the tradition and
so what happens is Ezekiel he is an um
Israelite prophet and he goes to heaven
where he meets all these monsters and
demons and angels and he meets God
himself and then God gives him a scroll
puts it in his mouth says eatat it and
he eats it and returns to Earth to tell
the Israelites the words of God and so
this starts the idea that a prophet is
someone who speaks the word of God okay
he said to me this is God Yahweh oh
mortal eat what is offered to you eat
this scroll and go speak to the house of
Israel so I opened my mouth and he gave
me the scroll to
eat in my mouth it was as sweet as honey
okay so this is the idea of the apocal
tradition what Dante will do is
completely
overturn this
tradition okay um all right okay yeah
next
slide all right so before we look at
Divine Comedy what let's review
Augustine because as we discussed
previously Augustine the city of God is
what
starts the um Dark Ages right because of
the way that the world is presented okay
so let's let's look at a few quotes from
the city of God to remind ourselves of
what the mentality of the Dark Ages
was first when men man lives by the
standard of man and not by the standard
of God he is like the devil okay and the
idea here is that the devil is within us
we must constantly fight against our own
nature if we are to be with God okay
second is now could anything but Pride
have been the start of the evil will and
the idea here
is if left to our own devices we will
strive to be like
God Pride uh in the city of God is used
almost
um synonymously like the word eego okay
basically who we are we humans are are
born proud and will strive for godhood
if we are allowed to okay third is his
was a venal transgression when he
refused to Desert his wife's
companion so he's talking about the
story of Adam and Eve Eve was clearly
the disobedient one right but Adam what
did he
eat the fruit because he didn't want to
abandon Eve therefore love is
sin okay if you love you will commit sin
you cannot trust love it is because Adam
loved Eve that he ate the fruit and
condemned
Humanity
okay although the will deres it its
existence as a nature from its creation
by God it's falling away from its true
being is due to its creation out of
nothing its creation out of nothing so
the question then is if God created us
why are we so bad and the answer is
because God created us out of
dust he created us out of nothing that's
why we are so flawed okay again we are
we are a failed science
experiment we say we see then that the
two cities were created by two kinds of
of love the Earthly city was created by
self-love reaching the point of contempt
for God the heavenly City by the love of
God okay when we love ourselves we
create evil when we love
God we do
good and the last
one in the Heavenly City then there will
be freedom of will okay this is a hard
idea idea to understand what does it
mean to have freedom of will in the city
of Heaven it means that in heaven we
will discard our
bodies and only our souls will remain
the body is flawed because it's created
out out of dust out of nothing but the
soul is perfect because it was breed
into by
God okay once we are once we are freed
of our bodies we have no more desire we
don't want have sex we don't want to eat
we don't want to
fight or tions will all be dissipated
therefore we will be perfect okay and
what what will be left are to enjoy
unfailingly the the light of Eternal
Joys okay we will be one with God and we
will know an eternal Bliss that's what
we're striving towards okay salvation
everything on Earth does not
matter okay so it is a negation of human
will it is a contempt for human love
love it it is a distress of all human
agency and these ideas are what will
lead to the Dark
Ages Dante is trying to rebut Augustine
and free us from the Dark Ages okay so
let's go to Dante and remember Dante
will be a rebuttal to all these
ideas all right so this is the Imperium
the
final level in the structure of the
Divine Comedy and Dante has a mission
his mission is to meet God and tell us
who God is because God doesn't know and
neither does all the other Angels around
him
okay and the reason why
is if God is omniscient and omnipresent
if he knows everything and he is
everywhere then God by definition lacks
in
imagination okay this is hard I didn't
understand but I'll explain it okay God
does not know who he is because he lacks
an imagination all right so what's
happening is this Bernard and Dante are
together and they're staring at
Mary because Bernard will invoke the
love of Mary to empower Dante to see God
okay so he's trying to channel Mary's
energy to empower Dante and not only is
by not doing this but everyone the
entire Heaven is praying to to Mary to
empower Dante okay all
right virgin mother daughter of your son
more humble and Sublime than any
creature fixed gold decreed from all
eternity you are the one who gave to
human human nature so much nobility that
its creator did not disdain his being
made its creature okay right away what
you will see in in The Divine Comedy is
paradox after Paradox virgin mother is a
paradox right a mother who gives birth
without having sex daughter of your son
is a
paradox a creature from its creator is
also a paradox and you'll see this in
Divine Community all the time these
paradoxes
then this is the Paradox
okay you are the one who gave to human
nature so much nobility that its creator
did not distain his being made its
Creature if we agree with Augustine and
say and believe that everyone is born in
sin and we are incapable of redeeming
ourselves from our sin then how do we
explain Mary right Mary gave birth to
Jesus if Mary had sin then then God had
sin in him
how do you explain that well the only
explanation is Mary gave birth about Sin
therefore she cleansed herself of her
sin before giving birth to Jesus and how
did she do that a mother's love for her
child right so this is what D
say love is about love cannot have sin
now I mean you hear this and you're like
no that's that doesn't sense let's just
say that I love this woman okay she's
beautiful and I say to her I love you
will you marry me and then she says to
me I will but I want $10
million so I go and I rob a bank right
that's love right what Donna is saying
is that's not love that is not love ask
yourself this question if your mother
and your child says to you mother I only
love you if you let me eat chocolate
every day is that love
as a mother you will say back to him I
love you therefore I will not allow you
chocolate every day I care about your
health I care about your happiness
that's what I care about I don't want to
degrade you okay that's what Donnie is
saying
here love is the ultimate
power all right and because she cleansed
herself she has so much
nobility that she was able to give birth
to God okay that's where nobility is
nobility is not in being free of sin but
redeeming yourself from sin through
sheer
willower through love okay let's
continue all right this man this is
Dante of course who from the deepest
Hollow in the universe he came from hell
okay up to this height has seen the
lives of spirits one by one now pleads
okay he's been on this amazing spiritual
Journey he's seen
everyone through Grace to Grant him so
much virtue that he may lift his vision
higher still May lift it toward the
ultimate salvation the UL salvation is
God right but look but look at this
phrase Vision higher still okay what
does it mean it means hey you cannot see
God you have to imagine God God is
something that you do not see God is
something that you imagine through your
will all right next one please thank you
and I who never burned for my own Vision
more than I burned for this is radical
this is Bernard he is the highest of the
angels and he
says his vision I burn for his vision I
want to know the truth and only this man
Dante can give us the truth even though
we are
angels only Dante Immortal man has
access to truth we Angels do not have
access to truth
this is radical and revolutionary
okay and honestly if the Catholic Church
actually could understand any of this
then Don would have would his manuscript
would have been burned okay this is this
is Revolution
idea do you offer you all my prayers and
pray that they may not fall short that
with your prayers you may dispar all the
clouds of his mortality so that the
highest Joy be his to see the clouds of
his mortality B just basically means his
fear his doubt
okay this to O Queen who can do what you
would I ask of you that after such a
vision his sentiments preserve their
perseverance preserve the perseverance
just means he's able to remember what he
saw okay so imagination is one thing you
can imagine God but then you must turn
this imagination into a memory and what
is radical about this is that the our
most advanced Neuroscience our most
advanced scientists who understand how
the brain
works they will tell
you this is exactly how the brain works
you imagine the world and then over time
you turn the world into a story and the
story becomes your memory okay
so 800 years before Don knew our
Neuroscience how our brain actually
works uh next slide please thank
you and I who was now nearing him who is
the end of all desires as I ought live
my longing to its Ardent limit okay now
Donnie is turning towards God now is the
time for him to experience God for the
first time Berard was singling he smiled
to me to turn my eyes on high but I
already was doing what he wanted me to
do because my sight becoming pure was
able to penetrate the ray of light more
deeply that light Sublime which in
itself is true from that point on what I
could see was greater and than speech
can show at such a sight it it fails and
memory fails when faced with such excess
he is he's being blinded okay his mind
is being blown apart he does not know
what he's seeing it is so vast it is so
beautiful it's so powerful that he's
being blinded
okay okay next slide please in this
profound ending I saw and gather and
bound my love into one single volume
what in the universe seem separate
scattered substances accidents and
disposition as a conjoin in such a way
that what I tell is only rudimentary
what he's seeing is this he's seeing God
as the universe before the Big
Bang when the universe was this pool
of substances that was chaotic okay and
then the Big Bang released all of it
into the universe creating our universe
Don is Experiencing God as the universe
before the Big Bang and he's seeing how
everything is connected but he's
Immortal he cannot connect all the
pieces he doesn't not know what he's
seeing he just knows what he's seeing is
so vast and
interconnected okay all right any
questions so far all right are we clear
about what's happening keep on
going so was my mind completely wrapped
intent steadfast and motionless gazing
and it would get GRE ever more enkindled
as it watched okay so he meditating he's
trained all his life for this one moment
and he's trying his best whoever sees
that light is soon made such that it
would be impossible for him to see that
light aside for other sight because said
good the object of the will is fully
gathered in that light outside that
light what there is perfect is
defective okay God is good they a very
goodness okay is in God okay so think
back to Plato goodness it's in
encapsulated embod in God okay it is
what is perfect and good keep on
going what little I recall is to be told
from this point on in words more weak
than those of who of one whose infant
tongue still bathes at the breast okay
so this is complicated okay what he's
saying is this this is now 10 20 years
after his experience of God and what
he's doing is he's standing by himself
trying to write down what he saw he's
spent the past 10 20 years wunning
writing Divine colony to share with the
world the truth of
God and
so it's not that experience okay that is
now gone it is now his imagination of
that
experience all
right and not because more than one
simple semblance was in the living light
at which i gaze for it is always what it
was before but through my sight which as
i gaze grew stronger that so appearance
even as I altered seemed to be changing
in the deep and bright okay can you
continue
please essence of that exalted light
three circles appeared to me they had
three different colors but all of them
were of the same Dimension okay so he
spent 20 years trying to figure out what
he saw and now he's able to slowly put
the T puzzle together and what sees are
three circles and this of course is the
Holy Trinity so he's figured it out okay
he's figured figured that the very
essence of the
universe the very foundation of the
universe is the Holy Trinity
okay one Circle seem reflected by the
second as rainbow is by rainbow and the
third seem fire breath equally by those
two circles separate but equal okay
these are separate but they're the same
the Holy Trinity
how incomplete is speech how weak when
set against my thought and this to what
I saw is such to C little is too much
okay he's figured out next next one
please but he keeps on looking what does
he see Eternal Light you only dwell
within yourself and only you know you
self- knowing self known you love and
smile upon yourself that Circle which
begotten Soul appeared in you as light
reflected when my eyes had watched it
with attention for some time within
itself and colored like it in itself to
me seem painted with our igy
Effigy so that my sight was set on it
completely there's a problem here Effigy
means a mirror
image okay what he's saying is this
within the Holy
Trinity there is an image of
us we are in God
we are at the very essence of God we
are within God how is that possible that
should not be this should not be
happening
okay this is the deepest darkest secret
of the universe now how is it that a
human is within God itself that should
not be possible we are
separate God is good we are evil right
that's what auson told us keep on going
as the geometer intently seeks to square
the circle if you want to know where the
phrase Square the circle comes from it
comes from this okay um but he cannot
reach through thought onth thought the P
principle he needs so it's a paradox he
can't figure it out this is the ultimate
Paradox he cannot figure out what's
going on so I search that strange site I
wish to see the way in which our human
effigy stood the circle and found place
in it how is it we are in
God what is going on
here and my own wings were far too weak
for that okay so he's he's been for the
past 20 years trying to figure out why
this is the
case but then my mind was struck by
light that flash and and with this light
received what he had been asked he now
has an inspiration he now can imagine
what God is he now knows the answer he
knows the answer he's figured out the
universe he's figured it out okay and
this is it
here Force failed my high fantasy but my
designed will were moved already like a
wheel revolving uniformly by the love
that moves the sun and the other stars
uh oh this is the ending guys he doesn't
tell us anything he doesn't tell us what
he
saw
okay we spent I don't know years
reaching this point
and Don has figured it
out and he's not going to tell us why
won't he tell
us because it's a jigsaw puzzle right
because it's something that you have to
figure out for
yourself this thing only works if you
spend the time putting the pieces
together okay and it's a lifetime it's a
lifetime Journey D has SP 20 years doing
this okay
so I encourage you all to on this
journey but you know what this journey
is way too long so I'll give you the my
version of the jiga puzzle answer today
okay it may not be the best answer it
may not even the right answer but it is
an answer okay to what joh is saying
remember this is a mystery this is a
paradox this is a puzzle it's something
that you will have to unravel for
yourself but I will tell you my
understanding all right
okay okay so let's go back to the
beginning of paradise and this is when
Dante is with beatric who is
beatric beatric is someone that Dante
has loved all his life they met when
they were 10 years old they and they
their families were friends but
unfortunately beus came from a very
wealthy High status family and Dante was
wealthy but not as wealthy as beatric
family so beatric was betrothed to
someone of her social status and she
died when she was 24 giving birth okay
D never forgot about her she wrote
poetry after poetry reminiscing about
her celebrating her he wrote Divine
Comedy for her
and to basically pay him back she invite
to visit him in heaven okay so now
they're in heaven and you would think
like okay they they're in heaven they
love each other they can do whatever
they want maybe they don't have sex
Maybe they'll just snuggle maybe they'll
I don't know eat chocolate together who
knows okay but what they do is they
start asking themselves questions about
the universe they're in heaven and they
want to know about the secrets of the
universe how how do the stars work how
does the moon work okay
so so this what beus says to Dante
direct your mind to God in gratefulness
she said beatric he has brought us to
the first star which is the moon okay in
in this cosmology the first star is the
moon I answered with the most devotion I
can summon I thank him who has brought
me far from the mortal world but now
tell me okay the first thing he does is
hey I want to ask you a question what
are the dark Mar marks on this planet's
body
okay why is where the dark marks on the
moon next slide
please okay
okay so they
talk and beus says your mortal mind
can't possibly comprehend the truth but
try tell me what you think causes the
dark spots on the moon and Donnie
answers what seems to us diverse up here
is caused I think by matter dense and
rare okay what what do he mean by this
let me explain what what he's saying is
this the
moon um has parts that are dense and
rear dense just means there's lots of
rocks okay rear means like there's an
opening so light will pass through what
is rear what H what is hollow and so it
become dark but light will hit dense
Parts like mountains and it'll be
reflected back okay and that's why there
are dark spots on the moon and this is
the generally accepted Theory but
beatric says no no no you're wrong okay
you're absolutely wrong there are two
possible explanations for this the first
explanation is the moon there's some
parts that are completely Hollow light
just pass completely through but then
ask yourself a solar eclipse in a solar
eclipse the Moon is able to cover the
sun completely right but in solar
eclipse there should be some light that
if the moon there are some parts of the
Moon that is hollow there's some be
there should be some holes in the solar
eclipse right and then and then she and
then she's like okay then your theory is
there's some caverns in the Moon that go
deep okay but I'm going to show you
that's not the case
either in the spiritual Universe he's
not talking about the physical Universe
he she's talking about the spiritual
Universe all light reflects brightly no
matter where it is because light comes
from the essence of God okay move
on all right um so uh can you skip this
please
okay you can skip this as well actually
all right so then then then she just
says this okay you don't believe me so
here's what you're going to do we will
do an experiment guys they're in heaven
and they're an experiment why because
Dante doesn't believe her Dante thinks
she's full of crap okay so this this
she's say Let's do an experiment right
this is Revolution if you don't believe
someone do an experiment all right it's
okay to doubt doubt is Heavenly it's
divine yet an experiment were you to try
it could free you from your caval if the
caval is all light reflects just as
brightly as anywhere
okay and the source of your Arts core
Springs from experiment taking three
mirrors okay this is the experiment and
you guys can actually do this at home as
well place a pair of them at equal
distance from you set the third in
midway between those two but further
back then turning toward them at your
back have plac a light that Kindles
those three mirrors and returns to you
reflected by them all okay although the
image in the farthest glass will be of
lesser size there you will see that it
must match the brightness of the rest
all right so here's experiment okay all
right there's a
candle there's candle and there's three
mirrors the third is the farthest okay
within and you're holding the candle
within the F three candles are these
images of you holding the candle now in
the third mirror you'll be smaller what
be is saying is the candle will just be
as bright is that true
physically it is true physically okay
you you can actually do this at home now
what's really fun about this experiment
is you can keep on going this is a first
layer right let's do another layer okay
let's do another layer five mirrors all
back okay are they still as bright the
candle the answer is yes how about a
third
ler okay are they just as Bri the answer
is yes let's go a million
layers will they just be as bright as
the first candle the answer is yes
right that's experiment it shows it
proves that no matter how far how far
the candle is if it is reflected by the
first candle it will just be as bright
as the other candles all right that's
experiment sorry hold on now guys let me
ask you this
question what is this do you
remember it's a God had it's what Donnie
saw when he experienced God remember he
saw three circles and inside were three
humans in
effigy this is experiment okay so he's
telling
us that God
is that candle that burns in you and
reflects the ultimate good it reflects
the
good and it burns in
everyone and it unifies everyone
together the more you love the bre of
the kandle burns and the bre of the
kandle burns the closer you are to God
when you love you experience God that is
why you are without sin when you
love
okay this is the
godhead okay does that make sense
okay go back all right sorry sorry can
you go back please okay sorry next slide
all right next slide no no no no no no
no no forward yes okay this is the
ending of the Divine commy all right
let's read it again now that we have
this
information here force spiled my high
fantasy but my desire and will were
moved already like a wheel revolving
uniformly by the love that moves the Sun
and the other stars he tells us here God
is love love is God love is the univ is
the force that binds everything together
it is the unifying force of the
universe it is the force that makes
things move
brightly okay the problem is before we
could only see but
now we can now
imagine okay God is I mean you can not
see God is something that you
must
imagine okay
so that's Divine common any
questions
about this so far
um that's a really good question who is
he writing to um who is his audience um
so he's writing in Tuscan rather than
Latin and he calls it the
kadia um so I think he's trying to avoid
the Catholic church right because at
this time um the Catholic Church writes
mainly in Latin so he's trying to avoid
the Catholic church that's his main
enemy okay because if the Catholic
Church actually understood what he was
doing they would have basically burned
his
manuscript right so I I know it sounds
strange but he's really
writing for the universe if that makes
any sense he's leaving it
here as a secret box and then someone in
the future is going to come and they're
going to read it and it's going to
entice them it's it's it's like
they're curious as to what this is and
at first they can't figure it out but
they stick at it and over time it begins
to transform how they see the
world okay does that make sense he's a
prophet he's a poet and so he's not
really writing it to make money or uh
because he has to he's running because
he has a moral mission to speak the
truth when you speak the truth you're
speaking to the universe not to an
individual all right
have a or did the manuscript circulate
in yeah no no I'm sorry sorry yeah duck
thank you yeah okay so
okay at this time um remember before we
we said that all running projects had to
be sponsored by a patron and before it
was Kings um so he does have a
patron um it's it's like a account or
something and clearly there are Parts in
the Divine colony which are appealing to
his Patron right but um he's really
using this as a pretext in order to
speak the truth okay does that make
sense he he needs he needs funding he
needs a patron but what drives him is
obviously not the money what drives him
is he believes God has spoken to him and
he believes that he knows God he
believes that it in the Divine Harmony
are the secrets of the of the universe
he himself probably doesn't know all the
secrets but he believes that they're all
there if someone is willing to look hard
enough does that make
sense okay but but but but you're right
he did have a patron yeah okay any any
more
questions
okay just just a small one with I really
like the translation here oh
yeah
yes okay um so there have been multiple
translations of Divine Comedy um this
man is named Alan
manobal and um um he he's the one I
prefer the most just because he's the
most um relatable he he's the most
accessible I mean there are there are
these translations by um Long Fellow
which is uh beautiful but it's really
complicated um
I
think um extra pound has also done a
translation and then there are
translations which AR okay so so there
are different translations uh mum is is
I just think I think just the easiest to
teach okay and and so um um because of
translation issues this this again was
written in Tuscan I've tried I try to
avoid a close reading okay uh because
with Clos reading you want to analyze
the word specifically the dition but I I
I can't do that because it depends on
the translation okay but the ideas are
the same okay but but but thanks so this
manable some people are
trauma okay we we'll do a lot of Clos
reading when we get to English
literature which is like Shakespeare and
Milton okay because then because then
you can actually do close reading but
with translation uh you can't do close
reading it it it it's too dependent on
on the trans translation okay any more
questions okay so so um so so so so so
can we do one more Slide the Augustine
slide and then we'll
end
yeah okay yeah so let's go to Augustine
okay Augustine says here man lives by
the stand of man not by the stand of God
he is like the devil okay guys we are in
God because God is in us God is the
candle the love that Burns in us if we
love the candle burns brighter it brings
us closer to God okay this is how we
know we're doing good because we know
okay our hearts will know your faces
will know people will know everyone
knows what good
is pride will be the start of the evil
will no pride is who we are we all
strive to be
better is was a Veno transation when he
refused to Desert his wife
life love is
sin love is without sin love is the
greatest force in the universe because
it is
God we're created out of nothing no
we're created out of God okay God is in
us God is with
us the Heavenly city was created by
self-love the love of God uh was created
by contempt of self all right so this is
a really important idea but the idea is
this love only exists between humans it
does not exist outside of humans you can
love money you cannot love money you
cannot love chocolate you can only love
each other because God is within us okay
if you love God you don't love God
because God is an idea you have to love
each other you have to love beus you
have to love your mother you have to
love your son
okay um in heav say there will be
freedom of will enjoying unfilling the
Delight of Eternal Joys sorry guys okay
Divine commedy says this there is no end
to the
Universe at no point will we know
everything we exist because we are
contining God's
Legacy when we imagine things we are C
we are engage engaged in the Act of
Creation that is God we are like God and
when when we imagine when we love okay
that is our ultimate mission in life to
love and to imagine because then we
create new worlds for God to celebrate
okay all right all
right so that was the first lecture on
Dante next Tuesday we will um do the
second okay